bour citizens of the
reject Nation accents all over the place
we are here and it is time to check out
an adaptation I've been very very
excited for for many years now an
adaptation of the Beloved Belgian comic
Les
a it's time for The Adventures of
Tintin Andrew how you feeling I am
feeling very ready for Le Aventure de
janitzio a andrio absolutely as am I
guys what what's your favorite comic
strip adaptation all right and try and
reach outside the superhero realm let's
get creative okay this is going to be a
fun one talking to me people yeah Dick
Tracy make a different reference Dick
Tracy anyway oh that's another movie I
got to see anyhow guys leave a like for
uh massive collaborations from what I
understand a whole bunch of notable
people worked on this movie and as well
uh subscribe to the channel hit that
notification Bell uh make sure that
you're notified whenever one of these
reactions is coming your way also big
thank you to the folks at prepper for
helping us edit these highlights down it
is a task and we appreciate their help
mightily as well if you guys want to get
the full Tintin experience alongside
Andrew and I see everything that doesn't
make these reaction highlight reels come
on over to
patreon.com the real rejects we got a
ton of stuff over there you'll be able
to sync up with your own copy of the
Avengers of tinson and you can check out
all the other stuff we got over there
it's a whole bunch of shows and movies
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included it's a good time and if
you want to support the reject nation
and rock the freshest of drips be sure
to check out reation shop.com uh we got
a ton of great stuff over there and
we're adding new designs all the time
including this brand new doctor HTI
which uh I've got coming in the the mail
and I'm excited for Steven Moffett I
believe is one of the credited writers
in this movie so it's relevant it makes
sense but anyhow before any of that
let's go on an
[Music]
adventure as you check your own time
piece yeah right it's was actually about
a real it was actually a real reject
text message oh was it
holiday if you're watching this part
second question what would be a good uh
Tintin or tant uh you know story to
start with I want to read one God I
almost thought for a sec when it didn't
say John Williams full right I was like
oh my God a step Spielberg film not John
Williams what it's crime it really would
be you know a piece of its own
everyone's favorite
producer don't give me started man put a
little respect on uh hey put a little
respect on the original Creator and put
a little respect on Kathleen Kennedy all
right unless this movie sucks I guess
but and what a writing team gez Sten mof
Joe Cornish an that is
impressive that was actually the most
exciting part of this to me when it was
coming out at first I was like they all
those guys wrote this down and the
collaboration with Spielberg that must
have been so interesting I have to say
your face is familiar have I drawn you
before occasionally this is so cool you
a reporter I'm a
[Music]
journalist uh-oh are them thie
gloves dog knows what's
up whoa you called it oh I do beg your
paron damn Jerry from Jerry's game Pixar
crossover I believe I have captured
something of your likeness oh lovely I
wonder if that's the original Comics I
don't know I've never seen or that's
like the original artist likeness or
whatever yeah yeah that's what I yeah is
this one of those map movies is this
like be wolf I never saw that but I do
remember the animation in the trailers
snowy look at
[Music]
this it's Captain Hook's ship a unicorn
on the front triple mastered double
decks 50 guns isn't she a beauty that's
a very unique specimen that is
absolutely from an old Sea Captain's
estate man a war sailing ship very old
that is 16th century 17th I would think
R of Charles the first Charles thei
that's what I said Charles
thei of course I I me too I said that
and he only too quid dude look at the
detail of in the background in the
mirror wow I'll give you a pound done
damn man you get a
haggling never haggled before ah don't
hit the ship oh no no
no how much for the boat I'm sorry I
just sold it to this young jet tell me
what you paid and I'll give you double
damn I don't think you realize this but
you're about to walk into a whole mess
of danger that's quite a nose yeah I'm
warning you get rid of the boat and get
out where you still can these people do
not play nice that's a lot of
information don't bother rapping it I'll
I'll take it as is does anybody objec if
I pay by check if you want to buy it
you'll have to talk to the kid it's Neil
Patrick Harris as the as the toy maker
it's not for sale then let me appeal to
your better nature better nature this
ship was once part of the estate of the
late sea captain the family fell upon
hard times they've been living in a
cloud of bad luck ever since uh-oh as I
told you before it's not for sale I'll
take it by force then what's his name
him every everybody knows him tin he's
world famous why is it attracted so much
attention that's the adventure you need
to go under figure out what Secrets do
you hold bust it open where is that
magnifying
glass uh-oh this cat's about to cause
some
trouble oh dang dang dude snow you
haven't seen the uh well that explains
why he wouldn't sell he's like I need to
discover what the mystery is nice my
nice shot with the magnifying
glass no snowy
[Music]
yes damn claws to the
face
wow oh no oh you broke it oh wow you did
break it
dog oh
o some things need to be broken in order
to be fixed or found something happened
on this ship we're going to the one
place that could have the answer come on
Snowy you need to go under your desk man
well at least it got hidden from there
so whoever whenever they break in
they're not going to be able to find it
hopefully yeah I don't know about
[Music]
that always wanted to ride one of those
Library ladders s Francis attic of mar
Spike h the last captain of the ill-
fated unicorn the ship set sail from
Barbados in 1676 on one of the most
ruinous voyages in Maritime history ship
never reached destination attacked by
Pirates everyone ate each other all
hands lost except for one Survivor
Captain lost his hand to a crocodile it
was long claimed the ship was carrying a
secret cargo black tar heroin but s
francis's last words only a true hadock
will discover the secret of the
Unicorn
the American yeah yeah cuz you could
tell from the nose I missed something
snowy they messed up your place we need
to take a closer look at that model oh
at least they took the
ship yeah they didn't get what they
needed yeah thanks to snowy and the cat
let's give the cat some
[Music]
credit Marlin's
bike
and now it's the opening of
Casper how'd you do that you think
you're so
smart hey not bad did you make that hole
yourself or was that already there so
now Spielberg has said clever girl and
clever boy in a film excellent had to
point that out yeah now all the bases
are
covered Co of Arms Why does that look
familiar hang on a minute there are many
of them all over the world world it's a
hatic he's a Pisces Marin Spike Hall is
the old haist
stay damn for a second that dog sounded
like a lion or
[Music]
something dude the
animation
jez I've also always wanted to Clos line
someone with a flexible
Branch
oh snow is the MVP yeah
seriously it's funny you made the the
Casper reference I believe Spielberg was
a producer on that film okay all right I
know Brad siling directed it nicely done
I'm loving the the way that this is shot
the way they're visualizing all
this ooh that was
interesting what of my
ship B is that that's not the broken one
right is it another replica it seems
we've caught a thief
oh
oh damn welcome to Marlon Spike Hall I
came to retrieve my property I'm sorry
I'm not sure I follow
you this ship was stolen from my
apartment less than an hour ago I'm
afraid you're mistaken Mr tined there's
no mistake it belongs to me Tintin
doesn't make mistakes I took it home I
put it on a c it in the living room and
then snowy chased the cat and knocked it
over and it
fell this one's pristine sorry it looks
identical where looks can be deceiving
yes they can why did Sir Francis make
two ships exactly alike and you have one
already why do you want another it's a
decoy ship what is it about this model
that will cause someone to steal it why
so many questions what's my job Sir
Francis hack was a drunkard and a
hopeless rep probate he was doomed to
fail and he bequeathed that failure to
his
sons so it's true line is
cursed what else have you found out what
is there to find yeah that depends what
you're looking for I'm looking for
answers Mr sakarin Mr sakarin it's late
I think you should go home that's that's
Daniel Craig right I think it's a Pity
sir I'm sorry that the Mast broke on
your model ship Sir I hope you found all
the pieces are so easily lost
yes thank you for the clue some things
are easily lost what did he mean by that
snow what was he trying to tell me he's
saying to look under the table he's
specifically saying to check underneath
your
dresser they came back and turned it
again great snakes line is Great Scot
it's all right I'll say great snakes
from now on yeah that's a good one what
is it
snowy
oh who's a smart boy yeah like you said
the dog the
MVP damn the one place they didn't look
yeah good thing they weren't that
thorough aha this was in the
Mast good boy snow an inscription nice
choice with the light Three Brothers
joined three unicorns in company oh
sailing in the Noonday sun will speak
what is from the light that light will
Dawn and then shines forth the Eagle's
cross Eagle's cross what are these
markings some kind of secret language or
or code one's a bird one's a heart they
were looking for this and they didn't
find it which means they'll be back yes
they'll be back they'll be back and Mr
tinting is most particular about not
admitted visitors after bedtime how old
is Mr Tintin thank you Mrs spinch I can
look after this Blended glasses too whoa
he's packing Tin Tin going bang bang is
the American the game is up he's going
to be back now I know he wanted those
boats but I swear to God I never thought
he'd kill anyone over it yeah who are
you talking about I'm trying to tell you
that your life is in danger answer me
who no no not snowy
yeah careful
doggo uh-oh yeah uh Swiss cheesed my
dude right
here dude he better not get framed for
it this the most bloodless driveby
Massacre Oh right the the guys who were
pickpocketing the thieves right the
victim's name was barnabe doors he was
one of the top agents at interpole but
we haven't got a clue what he was
working on oh I wonder who those two
voices are sound like Edgar raid
regulars Tintin we're still filling out
the paperwork police work all Glamour
and gun so hard to look straight not
hear those too it's okay let Sergeant
Angel and Constable butterman speak
think he was spelling out a word b o u d
j a n cariban Caribou Carib great
Scotland Yard that's extraordinary what
is worthington's have a half priced sale
on bowler hats
oh and a terrier one best in show are
you going to take charge of this
evidence positively never fear tinting
the evidence is safe with
us drop this good Heavens Thompson sorry
Thompson my mind is on other thing light
fingered list what your fingerprints are
all over that go on Tintin take my
wallet there's industrial strength
elastic Ah that's very clever yes I mean
knowing we're just a few steps behind
him snowy what is it boy what do you see
oh okay so that's the pickpocketer okay
yeah he got them
gloves oh oh dang ow oh he's so sve
looking look at that van
DIY oh no he definitely pickpocketed
[Music]
him get
him
wa no
nicely done I've lost him you must find
my wallet it's very important I have to
get it back and you will leave it to the
professionals you know the odds of
getting a wallet back from the police
what was barnab doors trying to tell us
when he said our lives were in danger Mr
the T oh no tin I didn't order anything
well that's because he
you
no
carabu d WAOW it's a destination oh no
buddy wow that's a great tracking shot
yeah I keep forgetting that this is all
computer
generated oh my God snowy you weren't
lying when you said MVP earlier
[Music]
absolutely dop nice run him
over oh oh buddy
yeah hit your ride with the ice cream
man I love how resourceful and
intelligent he
is never taken a shortcut
before utterly ridiculous don't mind me
the dairy was
nice
no is he able to breathe in there
that're going to ship him to
Madagascar not here look your side now
I've looked in this one already maybe it
was a good thing that guy pickpocketed
him yeah at least right now and where is
it where what the scroll from the
Unicorn a piece of paper like this yeah
that's Daniel CK yeah you mean the poem
yes the poem written in Old English yes
was inside a cylinder yes concealed in
the M yes yes I don't have it I don't
have it nah two ships two Scrolls both
part of a puzzle you have one you need
the other you need two keys to start the
launch sequence I will find it with or
without your help and then I'll have a
vodka martini shaking not
stirred oh snowy hey
buddy I really want to know how many
Adventures before this were solved by
snowy not Tintin yes snowy's the real
reporter here all right he must have the
scroll the question is what has he done
with it we searched him all over boss
cavity search was going to say she
search inside mrar all ha has broken
loose it's a disaster the captain has
come around what uh-oh he says you turn
the CW against him s right he sober up
again well don't just stand there get
him another bottle is this like what
happened on the old
unicorn
smart oh boy ah is it the dog from
earlier oh the Rott Wild right I almost
thought it was a tiger raer
raer jig B just stuck jigle yeah yeah
give it a jig not stuck you idiot he bed
it from the inside you play like that do
TT get the TNT ah not smart not smart
broken crates rope
champagne there are other ways to open
this door is that the smartest thing to
do in a inside of a ship yes yeah okay
that's probably what you want to do it's
not like we're close to the hull or
anything like
that oh boy ow
Bonk oh no come on buddy you got you
guys need to get further away H let me
use you for
cover oh
nice got
a got careful kids got bullets flying
all around oh this
corks ah the
champagne nice dude knew that would come
in
handy you sneak in behind me and Cat me
with my throwers down huh you're one of
them sorry one one of what I was
kidnapped by a gang of thums the FY SW
he's the grew against me who a
sour-faced man with a sugary name he's
bought them all off every last Andy
Circus sarin nobody takes my ship yeah I
think that's Circus the precious you're
the captain course I'm the captain who
else being locked in this room for days
with only whiskey yeah that's definitely
circus he's so damn good he's so good
with his voices I have to keep moving
try and find my way off this drunken tub
yeah don't insult my
ship
tub yeah excellent archal hadock there's
a long Bo up on Deck he's a heck did you
say heck how could you let them Escape
don't worry we'll kill him sir no you
can kill the boy not heck oh what we
should have killed him long since don't
question the boss think it's an accident
that I chose hadock ship hack's crew
hack's treacherous first mate nothing is
an accident true that it's all part of
the plan we go back a long way captain
hadock and I we've unfinished business I
want a hawk what do you know of the
Unicorn not a lot that's why I'm asking
you the secret of that ship is known
only to my
family it's been passed down from
generation to generation my granddaddy
himself with his dying breath told me
the tale and now tell it me now I was so
upset when he kicked the bucket I had no
choice but to drown my Soros when I woke
up in the morning it was gone forgot s
Francis had three sons all but my
bloodline failed I am the last of the HS
did you say three
sons
oh I know what sarin's looking for it
was written on the scroll Three Brothers
joined three unicorns and companies
sailing in the Noonday sun will speak ah
okay Francis didn't make two models of
the Unicorn he made three
hey Barnacles someone's locked the door
Barnacles Patrick Mr Jagger H bunk in
the center keep out of the keys he's a
Restless sleeper on account of the
tragic loss of his eyelids oh tragic
loss of his eyelids are you sure this is
a good
idea how do you stay sleep during
that
[Music]
shark I do love the balance between like
the photo realism but the moments they
choose to go more you know comic strip
or cartoon like with certain things
there's a good balance it's like in a
film balancing between practical and CGI
a shark is it Jaws catch up
Andrew minutes ago I see Spielberg I see
a shark I just I get I get ramped up
[Music]
yeah Bingo oh
jackpot the be necessities of life
Mother Nature's distilled
recipes jumbo nothing yet watch yourself
the boss
says now it's like metal gear you got to
grab him choke him to
sleep oh dude don't mess with the bottle
we need that that's going to be his Arc
throughout the film accepting Destiny
and sobering up yes
absolutely it's Alan is that the bridge
Alan the millanes night and go has
landed waiting in the wings for Action
Millan Nightingale cuz he's a grump the
sultanate of bagar ruled over by Sheik
Omar Ben salad dude the photo realism
it's so good whose love of music and
culture is matched only by his love of
Great Snake hey the port of baka
Morocco yes Morse
code uh-oh in in
oh damn snowy always jumping into the
line of
danger all hell is officially broken
loose
oh woo oh wow damn not
bad oh yeah I keep expecting the Indiana
Jones music to ramp up I'll go for that
team up that'd be
fun oh whoa nice sweet we love
resourceful
Heroes
ow now Full Ahead full speed there's an
ice bug right ahead
yes is it the other
boat it's a fake
out it's a b up they're dead maybe not I
don't
know what have you done we killed him
boss like you wanted no not like I
wanted I needed herock alive he
specifically said that no I ain't too
bright there are two boats
mishy
Den find them make absolutely certain
they never reach begar God I wonder what
he's a very pleasant gentleman oh sure I
wonder what this would have been like in
3D yeah normally I don't like going for
3D cuz most of them are just conversions
but this would have been a fun film to
see in 3d for sure the Sheik collects
old ships and this is the prize of his
collection o whing blue Barnacles that
is the
Unicorn the Ben salad exhibits it and a
bulletproof glass case in his Palace
sakarin is going there to steal it yes
he has a secret weapon the Millan
Nightingale but that won't be enough oh
and that is why sakarin needs you that's
why he made you his prisoner there is
something he needs you to remember yes I
don't follow you of course not I read it
in a book that only a true hadock can
discover the secret of the
Unicorn I don't remember anything about
anything no Captain can you get us to
bagar what sort of a stupid question is
that give me those you just said I can't
remember anything about anything I guess
he must remember at least his
geography I am Master and Commander of
the Seas ow Master and Commander good
movie oh yeah I saw that a long time ago
typical land lovers no stamina these
days yes I'll get you there
t whoa oh that was a great transition Mr
Sil my name is Thompson and Thompson
we're police officers a family company
are you all right sir we didn't mean to
start you let us help you into your
apartment thank you so much no need to
come in I'll be quite all right really
insist yeah yes I can't help it it
started with coin purses and sort of
went on from there really oh my haven't
you heard there's a pickpocket about
yeah what do you mean pickpocket oh a
master criminal these are the brightest
detectives they have to offer I'm not a
bad person I'm a kleptomaniac yeah I am
ailing this looks familiar Tin Tins it
is
Tintin he's even got the date it was
pinched
on thirsty let's see if there's any
fresh is that really the drink you're
looking for I thought you were a pro
when it comes comes to the seaf fairing
stuff
man I knew it was water he wasn't
looking for that's going to dehydrate
you more come and warm yourself
buy wow dude well you looked the little
cold so the we fire in a boat I've never
seen someone put a fire in a boat that's
awesome and it's going to continue to be
awesome
Mo Captain not
that what that his men are halfway to
bagar poor miserable R yes all right
that's enough of that yeah stop feeling
sorry for yourself it was s Francis he
was a figurehead of great courage and
bold exploits no one like him ever
existed in my family what' you think I'd
drink oh what is it snowing I'm going to
lure myself into the sea oh no the plane
from the boat we're saved oh it's a sign
from
above
yeah oh boy new we've got one bullet oh
God come on boy that's all the Joker
needed against
[Music]
Batman he comes right back up under his
hat stay here Captain Don't Take Your
Eyes Off of them as I thought Miss Lead
has
been your hands in the
[Music]
air he has no idea that gun is not
loaded did you think we might find
another way to North Africa that doesn't
take us through that Wall of
Death Storm oh boy what a lovely day I
understood that reference ha oh maybe
you can explain it to me then ah one
day yeah boy be careful you don't want
to be struck by by
lightning we sent to
1885 oh no Spirits for medicinal
purposes
only
D yeah it's like I'll drink anything
right now this could be my last chance
to drink anything you know in a sense he
is
[Music]
medicating W
hey
no no
snowy I mean you got to admire the man's
dedication I
guess no no no the fuel tank it's almost
empty yeah uh it's empty the alcohol in
that bottle may give us a few more miles
no I want it I need you to climb out of
the plane and pour it into the fuel tank
I would not oh no I would not trust him
with that P the bottle into the tank
just don't get near that
blade oh
[Music]
yep there's one for the kids oh God oh
my
[Music]
God it's definitely gotten the hang of
this piloting
thing
oh with the skeleton nice
[Music]
oh oh my
goodness oh dude
oo oh no my
[Music]
dude
[Laughter]
whoa Sonic punctuations I've run out
have run out you don't know what that
means Captain we have it's going through
withdrawal
withdrawal Captain calm down there are
worse things than sobering up yeah are
there that's what you
think is he see a mirage did you ever
see a more beautiful sight she's turning
into the wind all sails set a mirage
it's like I like you better when you're
drunk 50 guns the Unicorn oh he's
remembering now they sobering up a
little bit what else can you say just
got the wind behind her look at the
piece she set dude the sweat that's
amazing a hole full of rum and the
finest tobacco and the hearts of the
Sailor set for
home just imagining yeah the ship
crusting over the dunes like in Pirates
of the Caribbean at World's End is that
the one yeah fied Along by all the crabs
oh that's a cool
transition I can't imagine how long it
took to animate all this
for the red pennant oh is that one of
his brothers holding every sea captain
who looks upon that flag but he knows
he's facing a fight to the death so
Francis is a hack hacks don't flee never
they drink they run head first into
battle with a loaded bottle in hand and
shot into these yellow bell liy Li SE I
thought that was his hair for a second I
didn't realize that was that yeah
prepare to bring
her oh did that guy look like the
servant from uh the Daniel Craig servant
cuz remember he was trying to give him a
clue in the in the H maybe I don't know
maybe I maybe he's like covertly
undercover or maybe there just all these
family just these ships
yeahoo nice Mr Nichols secure the cargo
right sir oh yeah that guy looks like
the
butler who wowe
hello I was going to say how often at C
would you get your Ms all
tangled whoa is there a willow scream in
there what a I think so what a tracking
shot wow
yeah
[Music]
buddy oh
fun oh
wow zip lining is harder than it
looks wow this guy's really buckling
some swash right now he's a hack is this
a Daniel Craig descendant oh is it a
sacarin like a phantom rising from the
dead who Blackbeard what happened next
would you better I have a beard this one
did I have a beard something happened on
the Unicorn that's what this is what JN
says every day when did it come when did
when did I get a
beard and dehydration all it took was a
day in the Sahara congratulations
Captain I mean if you want to sweat out
your
toxins congatulations what an awful
feeling take me back this one's alive
check the other sir oh my God that guy's
all bones did you find my friend yes but
he's not in good shape I'm afraid he
needs a drink captain it's Tintin a
plane crashed in the desert no no I'm a
naval man myself I never fly if I can
help what is this is completely
transparent water yep you knew it was
tring Fe H2O stroke delet
oh no you were talking about s
Francis telling me about what happened
on the Unicorn the Unicorn yes snowy is
an enabler lives are at
risk no buddy snowy what have you
done I
[Music]
remember oh my everybody oh
no oh
God a Jesus
Christ Show Yourself Red Rock Red
[Music]
Rock oh my
goodness we got to figure out what the
right amount of sober and the right
amount of drunk is for your memory man
he needs a
balance oh no
wait nice the Pirates were now masters
of the ship the crew surrendered
granddaddy said that red rackam called
Sir Francis the king's dog oh a pirate
hunter sent toclaim their hard one
plunder y I'm on ROM tobacco molasses
and dates that's definitely Daniel Craig
where is it you'll have to kill me first
no I'll start with your men yeah they're
just doing their jobs to save his men he
would give up the secret cargo all the
dates
damn 400 way of gold jewels why can't I
walk into a room like that yeah we're
smou right now I was just thinking
that's that's
funny oh boy kill his
men re you gave me your word he gave you
the treasure re oh no no Bruce lots of
bruces s
Francis ack always has a the track up
his
sleeves let's
go how lightweight is that blade he
makes his way to the ship's
magazine magazine where they keep all
gunpowder shot I guess that literally
would be the magazine wouldn't
it you dog let's have
you oh no not this time
oh
yeah the Sparks from the blades got to
do the final right this isn't just about
the Scrolls or or the treasure that went
down with your ship it's about Legacy
this me
after ohy Revenge upon you my name you
want venance yeah buddy come back and
face me hurry T what we're out of time
Captain oh
boy was I love how they made meant it to
be so epic to jump in the in the hay I
curse your name and all who come after
we will meet again hadock in another
time oh no right so he kept him alive to
solve that mystery and then he was going
to take care of him oh yeah
oh it's not over the Unicorn The
Majestic creature who after your blood
sck he red Ram's descendant that's what
I said that descendant Sir Francis sent
that treasure to the Bottom of the Sea
he would be damn before he let red
rackam have it and he was but he
couldn't let it lie no he left a clue I
love when characters discover things
it's fun three Clues wrapped in a riddle
concealing a secret but only a true hack
would be able to solve it a drunk hack
means to steal it the third scroll oh
okay do they know the location isn't it
on the bottom of the ocean well yeah I
mean the the third uh ship has it's in
the Unicorn right on the bottom of the
ocean well yeah but they got to find the
third model ship it's no good it could
be
anywhere Andy Circus does such a good
job when he's struggling and he's so
bring up
yeah what are you why are you following
us is it the Thompson I think so yeah
that pocket picker is picked his last
pocket yeah he didn't take any money
it's not the money I'm worried
about oh there we go it's a good thing
these dudes traveled all this
way the melan
Nightingale
Ah that's his secret weapon
when everyone's
[Music]
distracted no I had a feeling uh
suar jeez my first visit to the third
world oh my God first visit to the third
world wonderful sense of tact the third
Mel ship yeah
those
hexagonal details in the glass I want
you to look after this are you sure if
I'm caught I don't want them to find
this on me just keep it in keep it
secret keep it
safe oh they got artifacts from all over
the
world
[Music]
yeah we going to hear The Fifth Element
music now yes
my
ears boing no they're
not jeez make medical
emergency yeah
clearly well
done no
grab Message in a
Bottle hello Captain
yeah
[Music]
you got zoom on those Opera
grasses
oh
okay
wowe how retrieve it my HCK how are you
allowed to perform anywhere this must be
a thing that
happens come
on get him snowy so
close he now possesses two pieces of the
Triforce yes zarin's got the scroll
that's worse than that what do you mean
they took your scroll tined D make that
three it was a botle of alcohol there
always is no no like
that I can smell it on you
well on the back of your head he didn't
listen oh a red sheep it's a Jurassic
Park
Park where are you going going off to
sary grab that bazooka over there now
it's an adventure of Indiana Jones a lot
of head drama in this
movie damn it dude did you hit me think
yeah he did it's not the right thing
damn it
man oh oh buddy yes
Barberino F I have a feeling it's still
going to work
out I'll have those thank you
yeah dude you called that early on
Snowy oh boy
W they're a tank in that thing Jesus
that thing's going to shoot right
through your head man wo
no I want to see them go on uh what were
they called the barrels in the water oh
sure yeah little little water Escape
don't let him
go
yes dude this is the coolest shot in the
whole film I'm
coming who
[Music]
boyet is boy waa
not
bad this girls are lining up these are
in numbers whoa latitude and longitude
42° North what do you value more those
Scrolls or hacks like don't listen to
him you'll never get away with us you
sour face sassin I will kill him oh no
not
snowy ah snowy
damn it man Saran has the Scrolls
they'll lead him to the treasure they
could be anywhere in the world it's over
I thought you were an optimist well you
were wrong weren't you yeah we failed
there are plenty of others willing to
call you a failure oh you send out the
wrong signal that is what people pick up
you understand cut the negative self
talk boy he can never let it defeat what
did you just say of course Morse code I
sent a radio message from the Caribou
Jan I know what radio frequency they're
transmitting on what we have to do is
send that information to interpo they
can track the signals and figure out
which way they're headed comes in the
pole now hey well any P they enter we'll
know at once and we can get there
first yes captain of the Skies now my
friend just need him to burp into the
engine and have plenty of fuel
yep what the blaz yeah he's going to
come in handy
looks like they beat them to the punch
well done well done I love a good
surprise crane attack he's all yours yes
we also have an arrest warrant issued by
both interball and the FBI your friend
who got shot barab he was one of their
agents oh the American
wow
that's ah hold it
uh-oh oh
out
[Music]
Bonk oh nothing like the moving Karma
guffin
yes it's going to be like the end of The
A Team now my Crane's bigger than yours
yep let's do a shell game made the best
Crane
winers oh
[Music]
jeez
oh
noar oh damn Red Rock that's right my
ancestor just as Sir Francis was yours
unfinish business until you could
remember killing you wouldn't have be
this part no of course
not o
oh damn
dude yes ow
t oo ooh a bottle yeah drink your gummy
berry juice power up probably is his
best
[Music]
chance
yep ow nice that would hurt so bad yeah
Jesus ah
uh-oh you wouldn't the legend says only
a hadock can discover the secret of the
unicorn but it took a rackam to get the
job done oh so you've lost again hadock
why don't you have a drink the
reflection yeah everything that was
rightfully yours is now mine including
the ship oh hey budy
nice nobody it takes my
ship oh man I knew that was his
character Arc we have you now here going
to say his ancestor condemned a whole
ship to Dr underr to be
precise you are under
arrest when you put them together in the
sun that's the location of the
treasure we hug around
here um Mar Spike Hall this where it
sank in the middle of the ocean those
coordinates lead here we right back
where we started I thought the treasure
went down with the ship Master H it's
him I've been expecting you he's a
descendant there was a guy looked just
like him on the ship on the ship yeah I
like he looks familiar where do we start
is the cellar still here I should hope
so I'm sorry sir there is no other
Sellar it was bigger than this
snowy yeah
snowy
oh you hit a
wall p through it yes he
do my grandfather must have walled up
before he lost the house and then shines
forth where's the Eagle St John the
Evangelist who was was depicted with an
eagle and he's called the eagle of
Patmos he is the E he is the eagle nice
Island the one in the middle that
doesn't exist how do you know yeah
because I've sailed those Waters
countless times of being there it's a
mistake unless it's
submerged Sir Francis wanted his
inheritance to go to a man who was
worthy of it a man like
himself h a man who could look at a
globe and tell if one tiny Island was
out of
place
nice
Barnacles Barnacles Pat yeah I mean for
as much as people dog this kind of
approach for like uncanniness like a lot
of the emotional stuff still works and a
lot of the
matter saw what was it was it Final
Fantasy the one with M Chen is that the
spirits within May yeah I need to see
that one cuz I heard the anime that was
pretty sick too I was all about that
movie back in the day and I haven't seen
it since was that me what's her name uh
oh look at them feathers perking up
all's well that ends well it's not ended
s Francis left another clue we're going
on another adventure yes 400 weight of
gold just lying at the bottom of the sea
how's your thirst for
adventure how's your thirst for riches
unquenchable yeah p uh sequel bait
is yes snowy I want the so snowy
spin-off
absolutely that was F that was fun yeah
that was fun I really enjoyed that yeah
I did too no it was a fun adventure yeah
man uh I don't you know what else is a
fun adventure Indiana Jones is is uh
rating this five stars on Apple and
Spotify if you're listening to the
review that is about to commence and on
Apple oh
absolutely uh oh my goodness so many
great oh Carri Elis was in there oh was
he yeah as you wish as you wish some
good old voice acting going on yeah
Andrew what' you think bud I really
enjoyed it uh I mean the from the
animation to the cinematography to John
will I I love all the themes and music
John Williams came up with I mean there
was a little uh I mean he came up with a
lot of his own things but I mean
obviously he's he created Indiana Jones
so you can't say he stole anything but
um I like how there were little hints of
Indiana Jones in there just from the
sense of adventure of course but um my
favorite part of the film besides snowy
of course was um I I just I love like
the again the sense of adventure and
mystery and just solving things and also
to like the character Arc we got from uh
uh what was Andy circus's uh character a
hatam a a hack rather I was about to say
hatam a had I thought that was a fun
little uh character Arc that we got to
go on and just an adventure with the
three of them it was just it was it was
a fun time and also Daniel Craig did
such a I mean everyone did such a great
job but Daniel Craig he really played
such a menacing villain I love just
seeing his range because usually we see
him uh at least for the films I've
watched him I you know you see him as a
heroic so getting to see him play a
villainous role was fun but I was just
really taken aback by the the animation
the photo realism and like all the
details that went into it from the shots
and the the mirrors and the sweating and
all that I mean just text so well done I
was just really impressed and again this
is at least for me the first time I've
seen a Steven Spielberg animated film so
you know I wasn't sure what to expect
from that and uh he just excelled and
obviously I don't know this comic strip
very well but uh it just intrigued me
just to want to fascinate me to get to
learn more about it in general uh and I
just loved it it was really fascinating
but what do you think of the film no I I
really enjoyed it too and I mean I I
feel like I I don't know again the the
complete history of of the Tintin comics
and whatnot but it seems appropriate
that this would follow a certain kind of
yeah serial swashbuckling kind of thing
that would be akin to an Indiana Jones
and yeah Tintin is a reporter uh you
know as as we at least are clued into
here and so I'm curious about you know
like yeah what a classic Tintin story
would read like but you know as an
adventure like this I thought this was
super fun and I love yeah the interplay
between Tintin and snowy obviously they
make a great team and Tintin is like
super resourceful um and then snowy kind
of takes care of the rest and there is
like a certain magic about that that I
thought was really nicely attuned to
something like this that has again the
medium of comic strips and comic books
you know as part of its Inception you
know there are things here that
certainly are you know coincidental or
that are like just perfectly timed in
Charming you know magical kind of ways
and I thought that they balanced out
that peripheral magic nicely with all
the other you know swashbuckling and all
the other action and chases and
different things and yeah like you know
for again one of these movies that is I
I believe like a motion capture and you
know face performance capture based
production uh you know that's a style
that can be very hit or miss and I know
people often Robert zekus is one of the
most notable people to have attempted to
you know popularize this approach um but
this is probably my favorite version of
it I have seen thus far I mean yeah I
was big into Final Fantasy the spirits
within back in the day uh but certainly
that was animated at a point in time
where certainly it probably didn't have
as many resources and and you know uh uh
uh just developments and and you know in
the capability that this might have had
and something like that you know or
something like the zamus movies is going
for I think a is going for more photo
realism minus like monster creatures or
anything like that in like a b wolf
they're trying to make these people look
real whereas here I thought that while
yeah like you can look at some of the
eyes and be like oh maybe there's not as
much emotion as there might be from the
actual actor uh I I wasn't really
bothered by in this case because the
character models are cartoony are
cartoon like enough that it Bridges the
gap for the most part or I was never
really pulled out like sometimes you
notice because you're sitting here and
we have all these you know technological
advances to go off of um but for again
where this is in its moment in time I
thought this was beautiful to look at I
really enjoyed yeah the the way it was
conceived and captured and and shot so
to speak uh because yeah like throughout
the direction just felt very engaged and
yeah there are certain scenes that are
going you know with these really uh
sweeping you know wers or just
interesting transitions back and forth
really utilizing the full potential of
what this medium is but also at the same
time there are other scenes that play
much more naturalistically that were
just as convincing and just as you know
sort of bolstering of the overall
fantasy and uh fancy of you know this
adventure and yeah I really liked all
the the you know voice cast and or you
know the performance cast and all that
and uh and yeah I mean like it ends
maybe slightly abruptly in the sense
that like they find as much of the
treasure as uh hadock was able to you
know hide in his hat basically when the
ship blows up I I assume is what made it
into that little Globe at the end but it
does make for a fun like it makes me
kind of sad that there isn't another one
of these I would love to see another
after watching that yeah and it's like
at the same time you're like well I
don't know if I would want the sequel
just to be like them going and tring 400
pounds of gold out of the ocean you know
you would want some other mystery or or
whatever oh yeah yeah but yeah I thought
this was pretty decently proportioned
for being a movie but with the spirit of
a comic yeah I I agree with what you
just said like watching them just get
400 lbs of gold out of the ocean I I
think the the thing that I would find
most intriguing is just like now that
they have like such a rapport between
the three of them and you know that
there's a chemistry there like that's
the thing I I found myself most invested
in as those three characters I would I
just want to see them go on another
adventure yeah if you add add the
mystery and the charm of this film to uh
you know I I'd love to see another film
that with them getting the treasure if
you will but um from that perspective
yes I'd love to see another one if they
don't make another one then I'm happy we
at least got this one cuz this was a lot
of fun uh in regards to what you said
about you this was your favorite
animated film of you know the Robert
zamas and then the Final Fantasy I have
not seen baywolf uh or final or Final
Fantasy or Polar Express so I can't
comment on you know if this was my
favorite of but like I said um the
animation this was fantastic I loved all
the facial emoting like and and like I
said the the way the tears were coming
off and the the uh the sweat and all
that just it felt so realistic for me
personally yeah there were a couple
shots where you could tell it's uh
wasn't but overall was great and uh
there were a couple shots like you were
saying the sweeping wers that one shot
were uh you know there was Peter jackon
I completely forgot that he's like a
producer on this too was he wow like
what a what a combination of talents
going into this between yeah like Steven
Spielberg now we know why Andy Circus
was in this Peter Jackson the entire
cast and then all those again like
pretty terrific writers and their own
right collaborating on this no for sure
this was super group yeah it was an
ensemble cast and an ens behind the
scenes of uh just directors writers and
producers uh yeah you had like some I
mean you had Edgar Wright you had Peter
Jackson you had Steven Spielberg I mean
that's the Holy Grail right there so uh
but I mean I gotta just pay compliment
to that one sweeping shot wner that they
had where they were chasing the hawk and
it was like it felt like it was like a
good two or three minutes of no cuts on
that shot I was just so damn impressive
and there were a lot of fun little
references from you know with with the
you you had them on the uh the bike
there and then you had the red Jeep and
there were a lot of cool little
references that Spielberg threw in there
so just a fun time I love the mystery
again uh and then again the the three of
them working together just trying to
solve something so much fun the
animation the cinematography the music
by John Williams the direction by
Spielberg on an animated film
just exceeded All my expectations I know
like it's hard to say that with
Spielberg like how much more can
Spielberg exceed your expectations also
to uh really impressive uh writing by uh
Edgar Wright Joe Cornish Joe Cornish and
Steven Moffett fantastic job it makes me
so I know we've talked about this a
million times it makes me so sad we
never got to I still love the first am
but it makes me so sad we didn't get to
see Ed R saying man I would really like
every time I watch an Edgar ra film like
damn it I really want to see that film
but uh just again every time I watch
anything that has Edgar Wright involved
it just uh I just always get so
impressed with that man he's so damn
talented um but just overall very uh
impressive film so much fun uh if they
make another one awesome I'm so invested
in these characters if they don't I so
glad we got this one it was just a fun
time yeah absolutely and I mean I I
would now just be curious to know
because I can see how you know I think
this has like a 75 on on Rotten Tomatoes
at least critically so I I know that a
certain a good amount of people were
probably satisfied with it but it makes
me wonder how this relates to and adapts
its source material like I can certainly
see a lot of aspects of this being part
of it but I am also curious of as to
whether you know a Tintin Adventure is
typically like something as Grand in
scale as this with you know crazy chases
and and fights and things like that uh
and you know it's like a pirate
Adventure essentially and I like the the
the generational of that but I I am
curious to know like how specifically in
the voice of the strip is this and how
like I thought the writing certainly of
the dialogue and things like that a lot
of the time was having fun and was
having a good time but I can also see
how this maybe is like a more
accessed version of what you know the
actual comic strip is or whatever um so
you know I'm sitting here having
thoroughly enjoyed the movie but I would
be curious to know if this if you like a
fan or somebody who grew up you know
with these stories uh you know would
feel the same or or if this is you know
exactly what you had in mind you know as
a kid reading these seeing it now um but
yeah yeah yeah pretty much pretty much
everything we've touched on you know
yeah for sure and I will last thing I
want to say I thought this film also did
a great job of M uh just building up the
suspense really making the characters
feel like they're in danger because a
lot of times when we watch especially do
animated films you can watch these and
be like I never feel like the characters
are ever at a danger point but like
there were so many times yeah it could
feel a little cartoonish at times but
it's a comic strip so I mean you know
you get what you take it still felt
vital it's still felt tangible there
yeah there were times where I always
felt like there were stakes and like
something bad could happen to them so I
I thought you know Spielberg and and
Edgar raen the ra team they they did a
great job just you know adding the
stakes really making the characters
always feel like they were in grave
mortal danger so I I appreciated that
from that perspective never feeling like
they were invulnerable to uh you know
grave mortal danger appreci that it
never crosses into being so cartoony
that none of the stakes matter and and
again like multiple times I was caught
remembering that oh this is an animated
movie which you know I'm sure a lot of
again the performances were captured in
some kind of you know authentic way
where maybe stunts might have been
involved but obviously there's not as
much physical stunt work on display and
yet it still felt like there was yeah
and there were a lot of fun surprises
like I was not expecting a a crane
battle at the end too there was some fun
creative uh stuff that they came up with
so awesome film just the time and place
yeah is super lovely so uh so yeah guys
what did you think of the Adventures of
Tintin did you grow up with this is it
one of your favorites leave your
thoughts down below Le
aventur one day I'll get there I never
did great at French but uh my
pronunciations were okay so I'll drill
that and and if you made it this far in
the video please uh uh maybe if you know
Tintin well suggest your favorite story
I would love to go and read some of
those um but yeah much love to yall for
now and we'll catch you on the next one
cheers all right guys well we've made it
here to the very end now listen up we've
had a chat gbt theme going and what we
have done is gathered all the data of
everything we have learned from you
patrons we have inputed it into chat gbt
we have hired private investigators
we've done the whole FBI rig we've done
it all all your private data is now
uploading to chat gbt and I have asked
them give me a New Year's resolution for
them to apply for the year
2024 and let's see what AI has in mind
for you let's kick it off all righty
Jack
Forest this year I will start a hobby
you will start a hobby that you've
always been interested in but you've
never tried it's going be great wow it's
very general uh
namari you will resolve to read one new
book every month ooh I recommend the
tales of the Hanukkah Bear yes
absolutely and Mike Joyce your
resolution is to volunteer in your
community at least once a month and let
us know what you did so that we can all
feel better about your efforts in the
community at large oh I'd love to hear
it Ryan Smith uh so 2024 you should take
a photography class to capture life's
Beautiful Moments a great thing to
capture in December when you catch that
Hanukkah bear going through your track
mhm you you're going to see that's one
of the best photos ever you could sell
it oh yeah you'll make millions at the
weekly world news Kevin Meek uh you will
be committed to learning a new language
this year and uh I uh suggest learning
yish so that you could communicate to
the Hanukkah bear when the Hanukkah bear
comes around that's a great Point Adrien
Tims uh you will make a point to walk or
bike more often reducing carbon
footprint ooh that's great and also
coming handy when you want when you flag
down the Hanukkah Bear yeah absolutely
you can get get him right quick nav deep
sidu uh this year you're going to cook a
new recipe every week to expand your
culinary skills and so that you have an
offering to leave out for the hanuka
Bear right next to your trash When
Christmas Comes again real nagas uh you
resolve to write daily whether it's
journaling or creative writing you
should write a story about the hanuk
bear I would read that story I think
we'd all read that story Heather G here
uh listen your goal is going to be a
small starting a small garden and
growing your own vegetables so that the
Hanukkah bear will have something to
munch on when coming through the
neighborhood keeping fueled up keeping
energized for the holidays so everyone
has a happy holiday Ian Simon is going
to take up yoga to improve his
flexibility and reduce stress hanuk bear
can get vicious so you might need to be
able to get yourself out of a bear trap
is what we call it and it's get it cuz
it's the bear who's trapping you and
flexibility will come in handy and also
you want to calm yourself stress will
only make it worse and uh Hey song High
Glover check this out this year uh
you're going to focus on learning a
musical instrument and uh I know that
pan flutes are you know the siren song
of the Hanukkah bear so if you want to
you know attract that priority you know
and get the best offerings you know
learn the panl uh Kayla the king uh
result resolves to travel to a new place
you never been to before ooh the kingdom
where the Hanukkah bear besides the land
of hanuk now you see like Santa's in the
North Pole and uh Hanukkah bear is in
Detroit
Michigan hidden hidden park hidden in
the W out there yeah it's good and uh
and hey Olivier Hamlin check this out
you're going to be committed to
completing a 30day fitness challenge
because you were going to become the
Hanukkah Bears of PR
all right and that takes a lot of
strength and a lot of endurance lot
stamina Alan ling you're going to
dedicate each time to unplug and enjoy
nature where you're undoubtedly going to
catch sight of the Beloved hanuka as he
she they travel the midst of the world
through eight days absolutely and Kira
check this out your resolution is going
to be to start a gratitude journal and
write in it daily and I Can Only Imagine
that your first entry is going to be
your gratitude for the generous gifts
and offerings that the Hanukkah bear has
left you this year of Our Lord 2023 Juan
Longoria plans to take up a creative
hobby like painting or crafting and if
you can start crafting a sculpture of
the Hanukkah bear that way people will
remember the Hanukkah bear come holiday
season versus the Santa guy you could be
something instrumental for the future of
holiday season absolutely spread that
cheer Cliff Rodriguez uh hey look this
year you're going to be focusing on
mastering a new skill related to your
career which I assume involves something
with nature and the outdoors and thus is
only going to help you that much more
when dealing with the Hanukkah bear in
your line of work and and you know your
professionalism will be appreciated
everyone will know go Nation going to
try a new sport or physical activity
you've never done before I hunting
humans who dare to hunt the Hanukkah
bear dude you are a part of the circle
of life there are people constantly
trying to kill the Hanukkah bear and you
know what you are going to kill those
people definitely and Lorenzo Baxter
check this out uh you're going to make a
resolution to attend more live music or
cultural events because the hanuk bear
though uh has Hanukkah and its name you
know is a bear of all peoples and the
more you know about culture and art the
better you will be able to appreciate
the offerings bestowed upon you by The
Haun bear differently saying resolves to
reduce screen time and read more
physical books I suggest that as you're
reducing that screen time Read More
Physical books start with the Torah and
then in the Torah you will discover that
there's hidden subtext the entire time
oh hinting at the oncoming Hanukkah bear
who makes his first life live appearance
in 1997 ABS yeah in the newer parts of
the Torah uh oh hey check it out Marco
tunil uh your goal is to save a certain
amount each month for a dream trip to
the homeland of the Hanukah bear where
you could see its den meet its family
and leave an offering you know you can
you can lean down and and you know pray
to the Hanukkah Bear right there simply
faded going to prioritize spending more
quality time with family and friends
why do that [__] when you could be
looking out for the Hanukkah bear
instead bring your family with you
you're going to realize you don't need
your family and friends if they don't
want to see the Hanukkah bear then screw
them they're not your real family or
friends it's a freaking Hanukkah Bear
yeah and hey SJ 94 uh this year you're
going to start a creative project that
you've been putting off such as a full
biography and annotated history of all
sightings of the hanuka bear throughout
time it's important work and we thank
you for it and if you need any help just
know we're not qualified for that you're
qualified for that Justin Martin
resolves to meditate daily to improve
their mental well-being and one of the
best ways to improve your mental
well-being offering yourself as a human
sacrifice to the Hanukkah bear loves to
eat a good human especially if you
provoke it Yum Yum Yum Yum and oh SJ
94 uh oh no no no wait Justin Martin no
Rosie batty there we go I'm back on the
list see I need a visit from the
Hanukkah bear Rosie batty you're going
to plan to challenge Yourself by
attending a workshop or a class in an
unfamiliar field such as Urology the
study of bears and in doing so you know
you can take your already pre-existing
knowledge of Hanukkah combine the two
and thus be one of our foremost Hanukkah
bear historians wow yeah Colin uh gonna
focus on personal growth by attending a
seminar or Workshop start with Urology
the study of bears sure where you could
become a bear connoisseur historian to
know that really in the hollow Earth is
where our Hanukah bear actually resides
you see in Detroit Michigan there's an
opening to The Hollow Earth and that's
where you find the old the Huka bear is
massive I'm surprised many people have
not cited the Hanukkah bear it is at
least 25 ft tall bare minimum and for
some reason only focuses on trash yep
there's a lot of trash in our world you
know we are a literate species and uh
speaking of Philip J Smith Jr this year
you are going to Mentor someone to help
them achieve their goals such as meeting
and becoming the next Hanukkah bear and
uh you're a real credit to society cuz
if you weren't out there doing that the
line might die there might be no more
Hanukkah bears after this iteration and
we can't have that Society will devolve
into cannibalism if we do Jen Smith
resolves to express her creativity
through a new art form I'm thinking
calligraphy that way we can document the
historical sightings of the hanuka bear
oh in its most pure form yes everyone
knows the calligraphy 100 years now
people will find it be like wow this has
been around for millions of years and
boy is it beautiful to look at Melanie
LeBlanc check it out uh to round us out
your goal your goal will be to achieve a
healthier work life balance so that you
have more free time to dedicate to
tracking and worshiping the Hanukkah
bear because let's face it you're
married to your job and the Hanukkah
bear knows it that's why the Hanukkah
bear is not taking as much time visiting
your trash all right so get that
together realize what's important in
life and go out there and be you know
the spirit of Han a bear I think we've
all learned something today yeah the
Hanukkah bear is a Kaiju that resides in
the hollow Earth visits us eight days a
week for Christmas for for Christmas
season bestowing gifts upon us but is
also a vicious killer yes if you provoke
it yes so it's a force in nature some
people think it's just a bear that
happen to be wearing a yamako this one
time in 1997 in Detroit Michigan n no no
Legend is real that's just exciting to
let us know with that in mind
faithful Merry Christmas Merry
[Music]
Christmas